how's it going bros my name is Pippa why
does my hair look like a turd just wait
for the episode to find out
welcome to five weird stuff online first
item we got this day it's what I feel
tingly Oh what's happening Wow I feel
fabulous do you like this outfit the
first item is this beautiful item that
you bros recommended it's just this is
kawaii
schoolgirl Japanese outfit do you like
it idem number two Aloha we went from
cute anime outfit to dragon meat well
we're just gonna have to try it get
someone to open this you know what they
say if you eat a dragon you might become
a dragon yeah okay oh oh it has a
distinct smell oh it's so old oh I'm
fine
alright well if you want to be a
fabulous dragon you
I gotta get sick it's pretty good hahaha
I feel feel different what's happening
to my body
I don't understand nothing changed
except this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
all are supposed to wire this I don't
is it the nose do I look good am i the
most fabulous duck you've ever seen
now we'll [ __ ] you then
item number three let's move on wait
what's that sponsor eagle has returned
from the great wide fields of Africa
sponsor Eagle what do you have to bless
us with this evening
mystical wonderful lootcrate like always
a sponsor eagle thank you a lootcrate
thank you whoa so this month loot crate
is cyber crane it has some really
[ __ ] cool [ __ ] in it I had a little
peek I'm sorry if you go to loot crate
comm sighs pills and enter the code
pills you get 10% off you're welcome
thank you sponsor Eagle bless you I hate
your purity part yeah well you're
adopted first of all we get the t-shirt
it looks very 80s I'm all right neon oh
[ __ ] yeah that's pretty cool actually
okay next up we have this what are the
[ __ ] business oh hello this is heavy
heavy things expensive remember that
Bruce it's a terminator
keychain with a brain chip let's go to
the coolest item which is this
Terminator head half skull endo skull
let's open you
goddamnit what why is it soft it's kind
of soft it's kind of like you want to
eat it why do I want to eat you think
you can put it here right yeah does that
work no what they have like this hidden
thing ha ha ha all right
Borderlands mousepad I like it you know
what I'm gonna use it right now
I don't almost miss this okay we got an
envelope that says ring sheet command
issue cross ring service for range it is
a poster of my waifu Oh what am i doing
oh I need to tell you something I forgot
the next loot crate we'll be heroes too
I'm reading this we're celebrating the
return of the good the great and the
gallant with awesome items from Legend
of Zelda what DC entertainment and more
plus our first hardcover book cool ok I
should now return to my kingdom now and
in the beginning do you remember I said
my hair looks like [ __ ] well we're gonna
take care of that right now this is
ultra violet hair hair or buddy gel I'm
gonna go with hair alright not gonna be
I'm not that crazy so let's make
ourselves look good follow along
why don't you follow
now this came with his instructions but
instructions are for [ __ ] so let's
just skip this go ah oh my god dude look
at look at this look at it look at that
I'm gonna I'm not gonna put that [ __ ]
[ __ ] in my hair
all right watch and learn brush okay
it's working pretty well it's not as
strong I can work with this and now I'm
ready for my rave party outfit included
better [ __ ] be cool Wow
my hair is going Wow oh boy wasn't that
amazing
press leave a like if you enjoyed
watching this video I'll keep doing more
of these I got some really cool ones
next one so don't miss that one that's
always Bros thank you for watching
a CNN everyone stay awesome bros
remember to head to look like a console
sake and into the cupcakes and house got
bugs everywhere okay well how do I look
you can't you can't see my titties but
here let me show you